community brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state schools credit union
it is breast cancer awareness month in
southwest medical the sponsors of this
next segment is partnering with the las
vegas american cancer society to educate
and make strides in our community angela
welcome to the show
hi thank you
you are from the las vegas american
cancer society of course it is also
breast care awareness month so let's
just talk about the basics of breast
cancer first let's educate people
absolutely
so actually in nevada it's estimated
that about 2300 cases of breast cancer
will be diagnosed this year alone
for women breast cancer
is
one of the most common cancers in women
no matter your race or background
not counting some forms of skin cancer
however there is some hope so since 1989
due to research um there has been a 40
decline in breast cancer related deaths
wow which results to about 400 thousand
lives saved
that's incredible um tell us more about
what is saving those lives you know
those cancer screenings the mammograms
what we need to know and take action in
breast cancer screenings is the most
important piece to it um so it's really
checking a woman's breast for cancer
before there are signs or symptoms of
the disease so
screenings not can't necessarily prevent
cancer but it can help find it early
enough where it's easier to treat
for many women mammograms are the best
way to find breast cancer earlier and
when it is easier to treat and before it
is big enough to feel or cause symptoms
so having regular mammograms can lower
the risk of dying from breast cancer and
currently mammograms are the best way to
find breast cancer for most women a
great reminder and tell us more about
the las vegas chapter of the american
cancer society what do you guys do
you know towards the fight against
breast cancer
the american cancer society in las vegas
works to raise money through a variety
of programs to fund research to improve
screening detection
and treatments as well as work to find a
cure and we also work with our local
hospital systems to help improve
screening rates and really get the
messaging out there that you should miss
your annual screenings and of course
also what you guys do is spread
awareness so let's talk about the
upcoming event coming
yes uh we have our upcoming making
strides of las vegas event this is
actually our 22nd year in las vegas
for this walk last year we pivoted a
little bit and did a drive through to
keep everyone safe but still had
something
um so we would love to have everybody
join us
and we are actually really proud of the
fact that optimum care cancer care is
coming in as a flagship sponsor this
year
um the walk is set first sunday october
24th
at red rock casino the registration
takes part place at 7 a.m the walk
begins at 8 30. it's a three mile loop
and then
optum care will have their sponsor booth
and their healthcare providers will be
there as well as the opportunity to get
selfie with chance the golden knights
mascot while you're there and they'll
have some swag for all of our
participants